[Music]
[Applause]
whenever people hear the title alice in
wonderland' usually the first thing they
think of is the disney version and yeah
actually that's not such a bad version
to think of a story about a young girl
who finds herself trapped in a very
strange mysterious land is much more
based on the journey than finding twists
or turns the character of alice is a bit
of a blank slate
she's the normal person that's supposed
to play off all the weird strange things
that she comes across it plays very much
like a roadtrip movie you come across
something strange you have an encounter
with it and then you move on to the next
strange thing like I said the focus is
not the twists and turns but all the
oddities that she comes across it's like
Dante's Inferno it's more a study of
what you're seeing than what you're
experiencing but with that said the girl
that got to play Alice is actually
pretty good her name's Katherine
Beaumont and she does a really good job
actually giving some character to this
person the dialogue from Alice in
Wonderland is not easy to recite and
it's not easy to make casual well she
does a pretty good job she's curious
she's polite she's nice but can be
pushed to her limits she tries to join
in the fun but often just finds herself
too frustrated and she's also very
logical which makes a lot of sense in
the story like this because this is a
world where logic almost has no place he
went the white rabbit
[Music]
but did you just say I mean yeah can you
stand on your head my favorite
characters are your favorite characters
I love the Mad Hatter I love the March
Hare I love the Cheshire Cat they're all
absolutely crazy
but at the same time I think the fun
with them is that you never know if
they're threatening or not their mood
swings are just so fast and you never
know if something really dangerous is
gonna happen or if they're just playing
along half the time I don't even think
they know you may have noticed
that I'm not all there myself
the queen is one of my favorite funny
villains actually watching her again I
realized I actually did take a lot of
the nostalgia critic from this character
just how quickly she can turn from
common collective to just screaming like
a little child I really do love pathetic
whiny brats in a grown up body but
somehow have a ton of power and I love
watching Alice trying to figure out
what's the right thing to say and right
thing to do because she knows that any
second her head could be gone and
actually that's a pretty dark aspect to
the story isn't it
how many characters do actually get
their heads chopped off in this movie
just because they don't show it doesn't
mean it isn't happening it's pretty grim
Wonderland itself is very different from
other interpretations it doesn't have a
bright colorful background it's very
black most of the backgrounds are black
but that's always great because when
color does come in it's always bright
it's always clashing and it always pops
some people have problems that they cut
out too much from the original books and
well it's a Disney film and an anime
wanted that you sir have to get whatever
you're given I will say with all the
forced Disney sequels out there how come
this never got one there is literally a
sequel book to Alice in Wonderland why
didn't it just change things around a
bit and start putting in some of the
other characters like the night the
turtle the Griffon there's a ton of
areas you could go with this but oh well
what I do like about Alice in Wonderland
is that it does make the transition into
movie form that's the trap I think a lot
of other movie versions fall into is
that they try to follow the book a
little too closely ironically with the
Tim Burton one I don't think they
followed it enough but I've complained
about that enough before Alice of
Wonderland is creative it looks great
it's a wonderful journey movie and the
majority of it works because the main
character is just so likable I have very
few complaints about it except honestly
I would have liked to have seen more but
I guess that's a good complaint to have
if you're looking for a movie that's big
on story surprises and character
development this is probably not the
place to look but I think most people
going into Alice in Wonderland know what
they're gonna get and in my opinion this
is one of the better versions
[Music]
Oh